et je sais bien que les prisons
débordent et donc s'ils se prennent deux
trois bandales parce qu'ils ont fait ça
en prison je vais pas aller pleurer non
plus faut pas déconner mais ça serait
mieux de les mettre juste ensemble je
sais qu'à quand c'est le cas à la prison
de Caen on en a mis une grande partie
alors là il joue pas au boule ils sont
comme des prisonniers ils sont entre eux
parce que justement ça déraillait trop
après ça inquiète la région parce que
les mecs quand ils sortent ils sortent
ils savent de la prison de quand donc la
Normandie tremble un peu en disant ah
merde ils sont là Jean-Michel la prison
certes c'est fait pour purger une peine
mais c'est aussi pour faire peur c'est
qu'on a peur d'avoir prison qui a quel
pédophile va avoir peur sachant que une
fois qu'il aurait commis son crime il va
se retrouver dans une situation
peut-être plus heureuse que la situation
il vit actuellement on vit dans une
société où on protège les lesquatteurs
exactement on protège et on chouchoute
les pédophiles
après les moins meilleurs traités ta
pédophile ça pose énormément
je préférerais voir des sans-abrielle
bien sûr c'est nous qui payons on est
d'accord pour
Cyril ça pose la question de pourquoi
tant de l'axisme à l'égard des pédaux
criminels il est là le problème de
société bien sûr pourquoi tout le monde
le sait pourquoi personne ne veut bouger
une oreille quoi il faut faire quoi pour
que les sites de bouger tu as posé le
problème tout à l'heure en parlant de ce
juge qui vendait sa fille à partir de ce
moment-là on peut se poser des questions
sur les circuits et qui est disons une
certaine compréhension par rapport à ce
genre de cas bien entendu bien entendu
les mecs dans toutes les voilà toutes
les corporations il y a des taré il y a
des tarés pas oui je vais défendre mon
point de vue qui est minoritaire et je
ne vois pas
je vais le défendre quand même je ne
veux certainement pas d'un traitement
que le mec comme celui-là mais pour
répondre à Guillaume par exemple qui les
met dans mon petit icône dis-moi je m'en
fous qu'il se fasse défoncer ça c'est de
la folie on ne peut pas répondre à
l'horreur de ces actes pédophiles par
l'horreur d'un pays civilisé qui doit
traiter convenablement c'est détenus
quel qu'il soit ce sont des hommes donc
ils ont ils ont commis
ils ont
commises partout tu trouves ça normal
enfin on est dans une résidence presque
la résidence des couleurs
si on les met si on les met juste une
seconde carte si on les met avec les
autres même les surveillants disent que
c'est impossible ça ne tient dans aucune
raison vous le savez très bien car c'est
impossible donc il faut faire ça en
France on a un problème on ne sait pas
comment les traiter vous me parlez de
castration chimique ça ne marche pas en
France on n'a pas le droit de castrer
chimiquement parce qu'on ne peut pas
sanitaire
il parle de voter des lois il a raison
mais ça ne marche pas
tu es la France de l'immobilisme non
mais franchement je te dis tu es content
de toute façon
de tout tu es une solution c'est il faut
éviter la récidive Cyril c'est le slash
Gilles et quelqu'un qui qui a le bon
rapport et des bonnes infos avec les
forces de l'ordre mais Gilles là
excuse-moi mais de te réveiller en
pleine nuit mais tu dis des conneries
bah oui mais en vrai tu connais pas
tu n'as jamais été en phase de ce genre
de mec tu ne comprends pas à qui tu as
affaire les manipulateurs ce sont des
enflures ils vont faire un mois deux
mois six mois un an il ressortent
des hommes non c'est pas des hommes
c'est des monstres et moi je vais même
plus loin alors peut-être voilà
traitez-moi d'extrême il y a pas de
problème je l'aimais pas dans un prison
séparée avec les autres prisonniers je
les mets dans la prison dans une cellule
avec un autre mec normal avec celui-là